okay we've been waiting for this on
monday the biden administration released
a report on stable coins which
recommended that congress act quickly to
regulate them we knew this report was
coming and i have to say uh kudos to the
biden administration for getting on top
of the crypto market and starting to
think about what the downstream
ramifications could be of
delaying regulations and having unclear
regulations
delaying means there could be
a big hole if something blows up and
that could create a contagion
or it could be
a black swarm-like event that's what
delaying has done to us we should have
had this stuff during the trump
administration i'm not saying that
you know this is a left versus right
thing because i actually don't think it
is but i do think that this wasn't a
focus for the trump administration it
seems to be a focus for the biden
administration for some reason
uh and i think that's a good thing so
delaying is really bad because this is
growing so quickly that delaying
that's like delaying doing a building
inspection until they put the 100th
floor on the building like you really
need to do the building inspection
when they're putting the foundation in
right does that make sense so now we
have these giant skyscrapers and we
don't know what's going on in the
foundation and god forbid they they
didn't build the proper foundation the
whole thing could come tumbling down
second unclear regulation means people
are going to take crypto companies and
put them in the zerg or panama
or other places and other jurisdictions
that
basically inoculate them from
regulations or exacerbate bad behavior
and that then makes it hard for people
to believe in the crypto space so
uh there were a number of groups who
worked on this a bunch of different
acronyms the pwg president's working
group on financial markets fdic you know
the federal deposit insurance
corporation
the occ the office of controller of the
of the currency i've never heard of that
one and so
if you just want to understand stable
coins
we're somewhere around 140 billion of
these and the trading volume
uh is something like
780 billion according to coin gecko
again that's just a source i can't
validate how good that source is but the
total crypto market according to
coingecko and some of these other sites
is something like 2.8 trillion now that
number isn't real
because that doesn't mean that you could
sell all those coins and get 2.8
trillion dollars
you know that when you start a program
let's say i own 50 of the coins and the
coins start getting bought over the next
two years and they go up ten thousand
percent a hundred thousand percent right
they go up a thousand x whatever it is
those fifty percent of coins were they
never transacted right so this is why
sometimes these market caps
are fugazi or not representative of
reality so lana comes to mind this thing
has gone up super quick
if everybody who owns solana had a penny
tried to sell it now at a hundred
dollars it would the market would tank
and go back down to a dollar there which
wouldn't be enough buy side so these are
very weirdly traded
uh currencies
when you it's the equivalent of in the
stock market when you have a small float
right if you had 90 percent of people
were the insiders who owned a company
and only 10 was being traded by the
public how representative is it if
you're only trading 10 if that other 90
suddenly came on the market would the
price collapse in all likelihood it
would unless it was such a great company
that people uh really wanted to own it
but even in that case the supply would
outstrip the demand in all likelihood
so
stable coins are somewhere maybe five or
ten percent of the market depending on
how real that 2.8 trillion dollar number
is
so the report uh and i perused it uh i
didn't read the whole thing yet was
pretty favorable uh about the
applications of stable coins quote from
the reports press release stable coins
could be more widely used in the future
as a means of payment by households and
businesses that's an incredible uh
statement
the government really shouldn't want
stable coins being used instead of us
dollars so they're saying like that's a
possibility in other words like maybe
you'll pay your phone bill or your
mortgage and stable coins because they
reduce bank fees that's the big thing
here the banks
have this big infrastructure they're
regulated they have high costs they have
high fees they're slow they're only open
a certain number of hours a day you've
sent a wire you've been through this
nonsense stable coins just boom you send
them they basically free to send they're
like poker chips
they are very easy to transact with
now the us government is going to need
to have a u.s dollar
that can trade like stable coins
eventually but the banking industry has
no interest in doing that because that
would break their monopoly on money
transfer and make it harder for them so
i think we all understand what's going
on here you got these rebels and stable
coins and then on the other side you've
got regulated banks
and uh this report says hey listen we
need to have centralized legislation for
this and you know what who can disagree
with that given the bad behavior and
given all the fines piling up and all
the fear uncertainty and doubt about
tether hashtag tether investigation so
some quotes from treasury secretary
janet yellen the absence of appropriate
oversight presents risks to users and
the broader system
that's pretty obvious i think everybody
agrees with that current oversight is
inconsistent and fragmented with some
stable coins effectively falling outside
of the regulatory perimeter again
you don't really need much evidence of
this we had jeremy lair on the program
and he's trying to figure out how do i
do this with the highest level
of
uh regulation and compliance i would say
compliance so jeremy layer was on this
program tethers folks warrant that tells
you everything you need to know because
i asked jeremy as hard of questions as i
could
and he came on the program he said he'd
come on the program and he did
he wants to see regulation and he wants
uh to have clarity about that as i
started off with the segment you really
want to have clarity if you're a good
actor why do you want to have clarity
and regulation as a good actor because
it gets rid of bad actors who might be
cutting corners who is
the canonical example of the bad actor
in this clearly it's tether and i don't
have to worry about getting sued because
tether is banned
from working with
citizens and companies in new york
they've been banned so they are bad
actors according to new york state they
are bad actors according to the canadian
regulators because they won't let them
trade and they just got a huge fine of
over 40 million dollars
the company obviously
tether is a big part of this people so
tether go up to 70 billion dollars and
although people who use tether feel
comfortable with it
i think
it would be more comfortable for society
at large and for the industry
to have this highly highly regulated
if you don't have business insurance you
failed
one of the first steps in being a great
entrepreneur startups should look no
further than a broker in getting great
insurance that will protect you and your
team and your vision and your investors
and your board members
here's how in broker works their
technology saves you a ton of time and a
ton of money prices are up to 20 lower
and they have better coverage than the
incumbents because they use technology
you know the story so you can go from
sign up to a quote and to purchase in
just 10 minutes so when you work within
broker instead of those incumbents
you're not dealing with large slow
corporations and the sign up takes just
a couple of days not these weeks or
months that i've experienced in the past
and the process is transparent with no
opaque pricing so i'll explain two
crucial types of insurance that you need
to know about cyber insurance this is
obvious it covers hacks that happens all
the time you just don't hear about it
and dno insurance this helps you if
directors people on the board or
officers and the c suite the top ten
five ten people at a company do
something really dumb and then you get
sued here's your call to action to
instantly buy custom built insurance for
startups i want you to go to broker.com
twist
e-m-b-r-o-k-e-r dot com slash twist and
broker dot com slash twist and while
you're there you're gonna get an extra
10 off if you use the offer code twist
twist that stands for this week in
startups okay thanks broker great job
[Music]
you